ces images ont fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux le 15 avril à Rennes en marge
d'une manifestation contre la réforme
des retraites cet homme est violemment
plaqué au sol par 6 CRS témoin de la
Seine une journaliste interpelle alors
les fonctionnaires
[Applaudissements]
maintenant
la journaliste c'est elle Anna
Marguerita photographe couvrait ce
jour-là la manifestation à Rennes pour
une agence de presse j'ai remarqué
qu'une femme se faisait interpeller avec
une grande violence au niveau de cette
rue là donc je suis resté alors que le
cortège se dirige ailleurs pour filmer
cette interpellation donc ça c'est la la
photo qui précède vraiment
l'interpellation de l'homme qu'on va en
arrière-plan alors qu'il essaie de
réagir à l'interpellation de cette femme
qui a été plaquée au sol et menotté
également choqué par la violence de
l'interpellation de l'homme au pantalon
blanc anatante de s'interposer avant
d'être à son tour violemment pris à
parti par un CRS j'ai remarqué qu'un
genou avait été placé sur son dos et
qu'un autre genou avait été placé sur
son cou et juste avant juste avant ça
j'entendais l'homme poussait des cris de
douleur il était complètement immobilisé
les mettait aucune résistance il ne
pouvait pas c'est une technique
d'immobilisation qui n'est pas interdite
en France mais qui pourtant peut causer
la mort et donc
j'ai essayé de m'interposer verbalement
en tout cas pas physiquement
suite à quoi donc un CRS m'a braqué avec
son lance-grenade vraiment
vous portant en fait sur ma tête quoi
sur d'autres images le même
fonctionnaire mettant joue les
manifestants avec la même arme un petit
coup qui peut envoyer plusieurs grenades
dans l'espace de quelques secondes donc
qui qui serait une arme létale si elle
était utilisée à ce moment-là c'est un
geste qui est complètement
disproportionné il me hurle en même
temps tu dégages tu dégages alors que je
me tenais à une distance quand même
raisonnable de la scène selon le journal
Ouest France plusieurs témoins ont
affirmé que l'homme interpellé n'avait
pas montré de comportement violent
impossible de juger le bien-fondé de
l'interpellation sans connaître le
contexte rappelle ce chercheur
spécialiste du maintien de l'ordre mais
même si cette dernière était justifiée
il constate un usage disproportionné de
la force la technique d'interpellation
avec effectivement le genou sur la gorge
ou à proximité de la gorge ça c'est
dangereux le policier qui mais sans sans
sa ranger sur la cheville du manifestant
produit de la douleur totalement inutile
et puis bien sûr il y a le fou furieux
on peut pas l'appeler autrement qui part
bille en tête contre la journaliste le
simple fait qu'il ait été porteur de cet
arbre à bout portant directement en
horizontalité alors même que les
conditions d'emploi réglementaires
stipulent qu'il faut que l'arme soit 45
degrés et que le viseur donc soit en
l'air montre que déjà ce policier était
en faute même s'il y avait pas de
grenades lacrymogène dans son lanceur de
grenades sur la base des images tournées
par Anna Margherita le député insoumis
Frédéric Mathieu a saisi le procureur de
la République dans un communiqué publié
le joueur même la préfecture
d'Ille-et-Vilaine s'est contentée de
rappeler que la manifestation n'était
pas déclarée et a annoncé 11
interpellations pour violence harem le
15 avril
[Musique]